foreign
big game big gay Redemption Arc still
going on
big gay lion hello Mark Carly drop in
some receipts
well I wouldn't call it a Redemption Arc
that's so I still say gay it's a big gay
Redemption Arc still gay it's a game
absolute private correspondence leaking
[__] and he's just as bad if not worse
than all these other people but
we don't like any of them so I respect
that I'll I'll enjoy the leaks well you
ready
boy oh a background uh this is a voice
message that Brendan sent uh mark this
is a voice message that Brennan said
Mark Harley after he had dinner with Joe
Rogan and Alex Jones okay and Eddie
Bravo okay
yo so uh we do the show it goes great
you saw most of it so it goes great and
then even though I didn't really plug
anything but which is all good
immediately Brandon exposes himself yes
it went great even though I didn't
really plug anything you were on Rogan
people not many people are Hollywood
Ryan long and get to go on Rogan okay
yeah we can't all be Ryan Long's Brandon
yeah we can't okay we're not Canadian
enough no oh we all go today metrosexual
enough if we're being honest
and Eddie invites Alex Jones and so Alex
Jones is sitting uh it went real so it
went Rogan on one side me on the
opposite so me and Rogan sit across each
other then callan's next to Rogan and
then next to Callan is uh Alex Jones and
next to me is Eddie right so that's the
setup and so uh Alex Jones gets there
and he's just eyeing Rogan the whole
time can see he's just like his random
he came like he's like no he's Alex
Jones coming Roman's Like For What and
he's like yo he just wants to see you
and so Roman's like oh yeah he's cool he
say it's random but all right so he gets
in he can just tell Alex Jones had an
agenda so as soon as he cut off just
like he's like Joe I think you know I'm
all over the news right now and it's
never been hotter in the line and I just
need a platform doing I get to come on
the show you know I think it'd be great
and uh that's my Alex Jones impression
and Rogan's like what and he's like you
know I just think you and I together I
need a platform and you need to let me
come on the show and Rogan's like stop
not stop you're not doing my show and
actually I think it'd be good you know
if if I'm like a gorilla with rocks
bathroom together and you met him wrong
he's like what the [__] are you talking
about literally gets in his face was
what the [__] are you talking about he
goes you can't come on show dude he goes
you're talking about these kids that
died and it's you don't think about the
consequence for me I don't need the
[__] heat it's not happening now this
is my up to this point there's a little
more but here's my thought up to this
point I don't think Brandon is lying
because Brennan is just talking to Mark
he doesn't know this is going to come
out so this seems like this probably did
happen
um
also
Rogan what consequence is for you man
you got 200 million dollars in a Spotify
account now maybe bad press
sure but again that being said I think
he's asking to come on your show to
double down on Sandy Hook I I'm just
saying I mean it's absolutely no no no
listen Joe you're gonna let me come on
and talk about oh there were no real
kids there nobody really died and it
really was a Scion that I could see Joe
going nah man like if you want to come
on and smoke some weed and talk about
space and [__] I'll have you on but you
know
it's like he won't even have them on
just to have him on now that's weird
Alex we're not Rogan but you're always
welcome here buddy yeah I mean you know
if you want to talk to 4 000 people
instead of you know four million yeah
exactly
uh I love that I said four million and I
undercut them oh it hurts anyway
um so I do believe this really happened
I believe that this is why I don't like
people I don't like I don't like when
people do this when they talk about free
speech and free speech and you should be
able to have whatever you want on them
blah blah blah blah but then it's like
well no not really not if it's
uncomfortable for you though right like
you say Alex Jones is your friend and
I'm sure he is I'm not doubting that he
is but it's also like
Joe Rogan always talks about like oh
every you know the he talks about it a
lot right how how all these corporations
turn on you and everybody turns on you
and they try to destroy your life and
you ask Jordan Peterson and they're
calling about they're canceling me and
you're the only person that helps me
they're literally destroying Alex
Jones's life over free speech and he's
putting his hand out going [__] help
me and you're going no that's going to
be too rough for me so I just don't
really like that like if this happened
and I again I I'm just saying I don't
doubt that it did again this is this is
hearsay obviously but again the context
of Brennan's just talking to Mark right
it's not he's doing a show trying to
impress anybody you know
so if that story is true if it's true
then I will say that that's really
[__] up on Rogan's part because that's
the point you have somebody on where you
should go look it doesn't matter what
you said if people you shouldn't have to
lose all your money for free speech
that's pretty much the argument
regardless if you like what he said or
not
you know yeah and again it's not like
he's he has to come on so that he could
be like no I Joe I'm doubling down I've
got proof now saying Sandy Hook was
almost and I want to do it on your show
I could see him being like that's not
gonna happen but but just like I said
have him on and you know you smoke some
weed you talk about space and [__] yeah
I like showing those clips Alex Jones
was sued for more than Norfolk has to
pay out for the crash that's a good
point Thank you lulu that's a good
[__] point
and and that and that's that that's
honestly that's honestly we're really
again I wanna I wanna preface this by
saying that
look it's still Brandon and there's of
course the possibility that Brendan is
embellishing to make himself look cool
to Mark I don't know anybody would do
that that's like trying to look cool in
front of a dog you're a dog they don't
care you know but it's it's if it's true
that shitty Behavior because then you're
participating in the very same thing you
say you hate other people do which is
just trying to completely eviscerate and
destroy a person now if this person is
your friend as they say they did and
Alex Jones didn't do anything illegal
period
um
you would you would you you should be
bending over backwards to help this
person out to go look it doesn't matter
what you say but I think in reality is
and this is just my guess that Rogan
acts like he has no God but he has a god
spotifys his God he voluntarily took
some episodes down remember that which
is weird why would you voluntarily take
your own effort it's like it's like a
good solid two three dozen episodes
right so you know I I don't don't I know
what the real thing is the real thing is
you get in there then you get embroiled
and that Joe Rogan's probably worried
about him being pulled into some future
court case because of something Alex
Jones says on a show that's that's my
honestly that's my guess you know but
then then again then you go look man
I'll have you on but you gotta chill
right yeah that's it I mean [__] we had
Alex Jones on it he basically made
[__] wild accusations about Matthew
McConaughey that was one of my favorite
podcasts let it happen we're like yeah
this is awesome let me my favorite Alex
Jones story that I tell all the time and
it's one of not not the last time you
come over the time before the second
time he came on our show
but remember before the first thing he
said when he came out was like don't
worry guys I'm I know we're on YouTube
I'm not gonna get your channel [__] or
anything 15 minutes later and I think we
should be killing government officials
and I'm like
okay
I mean it's one of my favorites I know
but it was amazing
it's a vow because it is I love
politicians and I just want to keep them
all safe and warm and happy
me too me too
toxic I know I think you'll be good he's
like stop stop quit [__] asking me
and then uh Eddie started going off
about some conspiracy on the you know
the government and uh Alex takes his
phone out to film office and everyone's
like what the [__] are you doing he's
like we're at dinner dude put your
[__] phone down don't blast this out
he's like what the [__] are you doing
and he's dude just Brogan's a Savage on
him and Alex like all right well and
then after he realized it wasn't
happening all right well uh I'm gonna
get going I appreciate you guys having
me and you're just like what the [__]
hey hey Rogan the lesson you should
learn out of this outside of
it's your show you could do your coolest
friend left the dinner yeah
and then do you know when the second
coolest friend is Eddie Bravo
that's not the best second coolest
friend and you know what I I like Eddie
Bravo that's not fair that he Bravo's
never pissed me off Eddie Bravo is one
of those dudes it's just by the way
somebody else who oh still to this day
you gotta accept Eddie Bravo still got
Alex's back no matter what no matter
[__] what you know so credit to that
so he's um but that being said it's like
it's not only having your coolest friend
go away whatever but it's it's this it's
it's you have Brennan in your crew
Brennan's already out of you for
cheating on your wife remember we
covered that yeah that's something that
Brennan did right Brennan outed you for
that Brendan outs you for gave you [__]
because uh gave you [__] about having
Mark Zuckerberg there remember that uh
he's constantly picking fights with the
UFC or employer yeah he's picking fights
with the UFC your employer and now
you're having a by the way the complaint
was that Alex Jones was pushed putting
the stuff out there not to Alex's credit
he might he never posted the video of
him talking to Joe he never posted a
video
um however Brendan couldn't help to brag
to somebody that he was hanging out with
such cool people that he had to tell
Mark Harley see that's the problem
dumbass you give him all this
information and then when you have to
fire him what do you think was gonna
happen huh
what did you think
you dumb [__] so look again Brennan man
you are just
by the way mark But update on that Mark
said if we asked him if he had told
somebody else that if that if we asked
him he'd come on our show
I just don't know if I want to send an
email
um
and I don't know if they'll be able to
read it
people